à durham la pression n'est pas réservé
qu'aux pop qui jalonnent la ville elles
montrent également dans les hôpitaux de
la région
avec plus de dix mille nouveaux cas de
kobe de 19 par jour
l'angleterre est le symbole de la
deuxième vague qui frappe le royaume uni
une situation particulièrement
inquiétante dans la région nord qui a
obligé le premier ministre britannique à
réagir le niveau d alerte très élevé
s'appliquera là où les taux de
transmission augmente le plus rapidement
et là où le système de santé publique
pourraient bientôt être soumis à une
pression insupportable sans autre
restriction dans ces domaines le
gouvernement établira une base de
référence pour interdire les contacts
sociaux en intérieur et dans les jardins
privés et je suis désolé de dire la
fermeture des peuples et des bars en
bars devant les députés boris johnson a
présenté le nouveau système d' alerte à
trois niveaux qui aura pour objectif de
mettre fin au patchwork actuel de
restrictions qui touchent l'angleterre
le pays de galles l'écossé et l'irlande
du nord étant compétent pour appliquer
leur propre dispositif trois échelons
moyen élevé et très élevé qui
détermineront le niveau de privation des
zones affectées par le cos vite 19 un
mécanisme ayant pour but d'éviter tout
nouveau confinement généralisée causse
veulent veulent bien sûr il ya ceux qui
disent que dans cette logique nous
devrions retourner dans un confinement
général national d'une durée
indéterminée
fermer les écoles et les entreprises
dire aux gens de rester à la maison
comme nous l'avons fait en mars fermant
une fois de plus nos vies et notre
société je ne pense pas que ce serait la
bonne voie une volonté de sauver des
vies donc mais également de soutenir
l'économie des mesures de chômage
partiel ont été prises nous
hamon pour accompagner les pubs et
restaurants affectée par les mesures de
confinement localiser insuffisant pour
ce gérant d'une pizzeria
aujourd'hui j'ai gagné 300 livres je
dépense 1000 livres par semaine pour
l'électricité pour le four à pizza trois
employés à 8 9 livres de l'heure ce
qu'il propose ça ne couvre rien
absolument rien si les élus de la région
de liverpool ont accepté de fermer bar
salle de gym et autres casinos les
négociations avec d'autres élus du nord
du pays s'annonce compliquée il ya
pourtant urgence
le royaume-uni est le pays le plus
touché par le coronavirus en europe avec
près de 40 de 1800 morts et 6 118 mille
cas positifs